was the purpose of starting a show
called the new Negro all it was to
create a space for people to exchange
ideas go to touch in a certain way I
like touch I do the rap stuff ever ins
of stand-up but don't try to brand us
and put us in handcuffs for fans up
Josie got some music
- it feels no but it's not confusing new
Negro some people is scared of a word of
the scene they was not aware of
we heard you believe what the media told
you demoed ideas get blown up behold
that new Negro this that in a third man
you say you seen appalling you sound
observe this is the new Negroes are you
excited I've been camping for the first
time they're like but you're a full
adult but I'm black I see this girl Unni
grows y'all both almost 40 the new
Negroes with Baron Vaughn and open mike
eagle Ramirez April 19th at 11
you